[Music]
is Kris Jenner engaged you've been
spotted wearing a massive diamond ring
on your wedding finger are you and Cory
gamble engaged no I'm not gonna answer I
mean it's it's the rings right there
it's a bit of it it's a real giveaway
ring but there is a ring let et set the
record straight it's not marriage number
three for the 62 year-old momager our
source tells us she's not engaged and
not married to Corey she was just having
fun on the show with James is your mom
taking their time with Cory whatever
makes her happy and I know Cory does so
I don't really ask a lot of questions oh
and in case you haven't been keeping up
with the kardashians it is getting real
she's the least exciting to look at
so the Kardashians have been clashing we
saw that on the reality shows premiere
as for least exciting to look at
Kourtney et has learned the 39 year old
mom of three recently split from 25 year
old Eunice Benzema we're told the 14
year age difference ultimately played a
part they see you go oh and there's more
fireworks to come Jimmy Kimmel tweeted
on Thursday night hurricane Kanye
strikes we are ready for you easy
[Music]
[Applause]